hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show everybody Black
Friday special it's the Black Friday
special we're offering an exclusive
patreon deal five dollars a month we'll
get you an extra episode every week $20
a month
we'll get you an extra episode every
week plus an extra episode every month
get it now all salesmen Oh all sales are
final all supplies must go get the best
of comedy and podcasting major world
this is there used to be a a there's a
big car dealership in New York City on
Northern Boulevard in Queens I used to
live a few blocks away and they'd be
like and what they would do is they
would get cars that people literally
were lucky they were in an accident and
they would just be like literally wiping
the blood off a Nissan Altima and they
would bring it on the lot and they'd be
like major world come on down these
deals are so hot and it's just all cars
that you know drug dealers you know they
would go to like police auto auctions
and buy it or whatever it was just it
was wild um it is Black Friday I didn't
go shopping today and get anything you
know last night I was we're gonna tell
the whole story about where I was last
night but one of my favorite moments
last night was some guy at a bar going
like this going hey his blood Friday we
should go to Target and then everybody
else at the bar turning around and going
yeah yeah we should go to Target and I
was like that's not a half-bad idea he's
like I think it's a great idea what are
you gonna you know go in there is it
even is Black Friday even still a thing
to people I know that I defended Black
Friday because like I know that a lot of
like you know upper-middle class people
look down on it but there are people out
there that [ __ ] need deals so it is
what it is and they you know they need
to go out and [ __ ] you know swing a
bike lock around so they could grab a
[ __ ]
a wave and [ __ ] run out of Walmart it
is what it is there are people that are
in that circumstance so I've always
defended like and I know it's crass and
you know is you know it's vulgar and
it's you know it's everything that's
wrong with America but it's like you
know as long as we're all living in this
system we might as well take advantage
of its dwindling benefits and one of
them would be you know at 2:00 a.m.
going in and [ __ ] you know going into
a [ __ ] target mosh pit and pulling
out a few [ __ ] you know toasters or
whatever you get I don't know
a few uh a few backpacks for the kids I
don't know what target even sells but I
would imagine they have those things you
know I mean every you know we used to
grow up you would see some then there
was a stampede I think in Long Island
there was a stampede and I'm pretty sure
it was a Walmart and then everybody was
like we have to do some soul-searching
because of this stampede at a Walmart I
believe look when that stampede happened
because I'm pretty sure it was around
the time we were kidnapping people and
torturing them and underground prisons
that no and no one had an issue with
that but it was the Black Friday
Stampede that really got 2014 it looks
like was it 2014 I guess it was but I
mean people used to buy don't even think
now there's cyber monday hmm and there's
other you know opportunities what a
Thanksgiving I had last night let me
tell you let me tell you folks if you
don't have a family you should be
legally prohibited from celebrating
Thanksgiving because it's really not for
you and I said to a friend of Mike's
you're both gonna be in LA now I could
have flown home to be with my family but
I chose not to because I'm gonna be back
in town for Christmas and I'm like I
just I'm on planes all the time I just
can't do it I just can't make it happen
so I was in LA and I said to a friend of
mine I'm like why don't we can go out to
dinner which is you never go out on
Thanksgiving you never ever go out on
thanks you do not leave your [ __ ]
house ever on Thanksgiving I don't know
why I forgot that I don't know why that
didn't died there for whatever reason
that idea didn't register
like well I'm in LA and things are
different with it but you don't you sit
on your couch and you [ __ ] eat
stuffing and you listen to your aunt
talk you know talk about queueing on
what you don't do is [ __ ] travel you
just don't do it it's just not what you
should do and I forgot that and I and I
was looking at places that have
Thanksgivings and I find this place in
Calabasas which is where like the
Kardashians of it's out by Malibu's
about an hour from my home in West
Hollywood it's about a solid hour it's
out there in the canyons with Kanye and
[ __ ] you know there's big houses out
there and you know go [ __ ] your mother
money and they have this place called
The Saddle Peak lodge and The Saddle
Peak Lodge Rogan loves it it looks like
it's got it's got big moose heads and
elk and you know it's a [ __ ] Lodge
you know it it looks exactly what you
think you know some Illuminati you know
Mason Lodge would look like and it's in
Calabasas and supposedly you know it's
good food or whatever so I'm like oh
we'll do it and it was hard to get in
because I ladies got a lot of people
that came to LA and for whatever reason
they're still in LA and they are just
they go out to dinner because they're
either older or then I mean we were
looking around we got to this rest first
of all it's an hour it's raining it's
torrential rain we get into an uber my
friend shows up my house we're getting a
[ __ ] Auber its torrential rain it's a
it's 56 minutes in torrential rain in an
uber and by the way it's not it's
through canyons and up mountain it's
crazy we think and there's people that
are rich so and we got a late
reservation at 6:45 so the people on the
road are already drunk they're already
coming back from things hammered so like
the guy stopping and she's swerving in
and out of lanes just to avoid these
people that are shit-faced and left
their [ __ ] family party so we're
heading to this [ __ ] we're heading to
this Lodge in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere to have a Thanksgiving we get
there we get there and by the way what I
say
this place is hidden it's an
understatement it is dark you cannot see
anything my friend is mad my friend who
I love but he's like oh he's a pouty
[ __ ] like he's pouty he's one of these
guys who doesn't tell you he's angry he
pouts he's got the frame of a woman he
[ __ ] a lot of hot chicks he's got the
frame of not now he's got a girlfriend
but he's got the frame of a woman and he
acts very womanly in and and you know
EEE pouch he pouts he wins he wins in
pouts you know and so he's like already
whining and pest who as soon as we get
into the [ __ ] uber it's a probably go
for ways all right all right you know
it's far away we get there there is an
ambulance outside there's a stretcher
outside I walk in I tell them I said we
have a reservation for two for 6:45 the
the maitre d or the ho whatever she goes
okay we're having a little issue here
because there's two ambulances outside
in any stretcher and I said oh that's
good I'm having an issue - it's called
Thanksgiving dinner and it's it's 6:45
for two people that would be my issue
and I'm glad that you're having an issue
but let's all have the issues together
let me have so she I'm not taking those
[ __ ] is what I'm saying if you're
killing people with your food and
they're leaving in stretchers that's
clearly not my issue now many of the
people in in LA because they are demons
from hell agree with me and they are now
mad that their tables are not ready and
an uncomfortable amount of people are
now start out cluttered around the
maitre d and we don't give a [ __ ] and we
do not care at all so the the EMTs come
in they bring down this nine year old
woman who's bombed who's just the whites
in hit her or whatever and they she's
asleep and they put her on the stretcher
and they take her out by the way this is
great Thanksgiving you just show up to
the restaurant and and somebody's
leaving in a stretcher that's it's a
great welcome
Happy Thanksgiving so we get there
there's this old woman on a stretcher
hammered asleep okay and and we're
having none of it because we've all been
waiting 15 or 20 minutes I'm
we're having none of it okay we're mad
at this woman we're judging her somebody
else cuz I bet she's just drunk and I'm
like I bet she is too she's just this 90
year old woman came here and she got
shit-faced and now she's got you know
whatever she fell asleep at the table or
whatever so I go to the after they clear
the nine year old woman out I go back to
the hostess and go listen there's
clearly a table open now right I mean
there's clearly we I mean she's out so
and she goes well I don't know if her
party is going to leave and I go you you
don't know if her party is leaving
they're gonna sit that one of them just
got taken out in his stretcher and
they're gonna sit there any cranberry
sauce kick him out get him out of here
and she goes why I don't know if they're
leaving but we'll we'll see don't worry
we're gonna set the table shortly it's
it's like amazing to me some guys in
there with a service dog a little collie
who's running around with a service and
I said I said that my friend Michael I
said god help them I said if this food
is not good I am gonna leave in a
stretcher because the reality is there's
no ubers III I was like there's no way
in Hoover's gonna we're [ __ ] and I'm
genuinely gonna call an ambulance to
leave if I have to I'm dead serious
no no no part of me is kidding I'm like
I will call an ambulance and give a fake
name like I've said many times before
and I will kick the door open and jump
out of the ambulance and leave okay am i
Michael is getting a little
uncomfortable because he knows I'm not
I'm not know part of me is kidding so we
finally sit down in this [ __ ] Lodge
and we're looking around and I mean it
is it is the Damned it is the Damned in
this place people without families older
people there's like a mom with two older
daughters you could tell the Dodgers
died like they're very sad and you could
tell the dad just died there's a table
of like older people it early says
loudly to the whole table of people he
goes I wasn't supposed to be here so
that's the that's the mood everyone's in
some people are leaving in stretchers so
everyone knows that they're there
they failed whatever you're supposed to
be in a home with family you're not
supposed to be in this Lodge now now to
top it off the food is also atrocious
which is great it's Thanksgiving
catering hall food it's B it's just bad
it's just not good I'm sure it's a
decent restaurant when it's normal so
I'm like the food sucks and of course my
friend there's this new thing where
people start defending the restaurant
now like this happens a lot people now
like what I'll comment on something
people start defending the right like my
friend Michaels like you know it's very
hard to make food for this amount of
people I'm like well then do it for free
if it's that hard we're all paying money
for this figure out a way to do it I
mean this is grotesque one guy just
literally yells at the top of his lungs
I swear to God in the middle of the
ego's it's not hot and then he's with
some chick she goes I like it cold and
he goes well I don't I want it hot it's
Thanksgiving so the poor manager goes
over to their table and this guy I wish
had a photo of them he was just he was
the same guy that said I wasn't even
supposed to be here he's having a
full-on breakdown because this is his
life it is bad and it's Thanksgiving and
we're in the middle of a rainstorm in
this [ __ ] hunting lodge and he's at
this table of people and no one cares
about anybody and there's no love and
all we want is the food to be [ __ ]
hot just make it hot and he calls the
manager over and he goes listen he goes
I want it hot it isn't hot he swear to
God he goes like this is the manager he
goes put your finger in it the match is
like I don't want to touch it
I believe you the manager is like I
believe you the guy's like no touch it
the guy takes the manager's finger and
he puts it in the stuffing and smash
goes yeah that's that is called he goes
okay so the manager now the poor manager
is shot everybody here is shot it is a
rainstorm it is nasty we finally get
through dinner it's not good you know
one of the waitresses it was an older
woman she was funny what kind of we're
kind of kidding around with her
and um at the end of the meal I go to
try to call an uber and there are no
cars available there are no cars so we
are in Malibu we're in a canyon there
are no cars there is no way to leave now
we now we now cannot leave and so we
finally get an uber he's like you know I
don't know 30 minutes away I mean it's
ridiculous he's like 17 minutes away he
finally arrives and I don't know where
he is now so I call it and this is a
thing that uber drivers were they they
they don't they can't hear you but I
think they can't hear you and they just
keep saying hello like I was like where
are you and he's like whole I'm like
where are you I forget his name was like
are mean I'm like are mean where are you
he's like oh ho I'm like are mean he
goes I am a good place I'm like you're
not here or mean you're not anywhere I
said now I am in the middle of the
canyon in the rain I've left the
restaurant I'm walking up a block in the
rain about to get [ __ ] pummeled by a
mountain lion screaming into my phone
are me where are you I'm getting wet our
meat I'm wet so our mean just hangs up
and cancels the ride which I get charged
$13 for and then I get [ __ ] that I go
to uber and be like okay the guy didn't
show up the guy's nowhere to be found
so we go back in this place we go back
in the place we're now sitting at the
bar and then this place also attracts
just there's a there's a type of rich
person in California who's very earthy
and like they're old hippies and their
parents were hippies but they have a lot
of money and they inherited these big
houses in like Laurel Canyon or Malibu
or whatever and me embed it into some of
these houses and they're like you know
and they these people look like [ __ ] but
they're loaded and they're all sitting
at the bar and that's the guy that goes
you know we should all go to Target I'm
like that's not a half-bad idea it is
Black Friday
so finally we call over the maitre d we
go can we get a cab so she calls a cab
the cab is an hour away so we have to
sit we're sitting now at the bar now you
think the people in the dining room are
damned
you have no idea that
the group of the crew that is at the bar
on Thanksgiving at this hunting lodge
okay
one guy is literally literally just
talking about cancer to no one he's
sitting at the bar and just talking
about different kinds of cancer and
every now and then the bartender nods
and fills up his glass and he's just
going on he's like yeah my sister
there's Hodgkins there's non-hodgkin
it's just so and then me and Michael
they're Michael's of course being a
pouty [ __ ] she's like you know is a lot
of money this was a lot of money and you
know he's being a conte and you want to
just hold off and smack him in the face
you know and we're waiting there we're
waiting there with it finally the cab
comes this is now we get in the cab now
it's a solid hour to get to the comedy
store in the rain in the traffic and the
rain or in a cab
a hundred dollars to get back to us
Hollywood the whole night the dinner was
300 there was a hundred and the breh
back was a hundred so is a $500 night
the food was horrific
it was just maybe one of the worst
experiences we've ever had the room full
of people we were we were all aware of
how we looked at each other like yep and
just gulped because we knew why we were
there we were there because we had made
choices that led us away from the warmth
of others we've made choices that have
led us in the other direction of the
embrace of our loved ones we had gone
the other way and now we're sitting in
this [ __ ] hunting lodge eating cold
lobster bisque
that's not even lobster bisque it's
literally butternut squash soup that
they just threw Lobster in its literally
put the waitress over I go this is
butternut squash soup she starts
laughing yeah I'm like what are you
doing okay I just you shouldn't leave
your home on Thanksgiving Christmas you
can go out Christmas is different
Christmas has a different vibe there are
people that go out for Christmas it's
split up into two nights Christmas Eve
and Christmas Day so some people will go
out of Christmas Eve or some people go
out of Christmas Day and they do the
family the other night and some people
have to do Thanksgiving if you are in a
rush
you are damned you are absolutely 100%
damned that is it you have made poor
choices and this is that and it's sad
it's very very sad you know and it
really just it [ __ ] really made me
think in that cab on the way back and
then my friend Michael goes to sleep he
just starts Slee he sleeps the whole
ride back because you know he's the god
of trouble getting up in the morning so
I just have to sleep so I'm alone I even
no one to talk to and a service there's
no service and it's just the rain and
we're just driving through this Canyon
and we're in traffic and I look at all
the other cars and I imagine they have
families and them families whose tummies
are all full with Thanksgiving food and
I'm coming down like hungry again
because it's two hours into it so I go
to comics right you start eating cold
Pete's and the kids to the comedy store
the waitress I'm like this is I mean how
how much worse could does this get how
much worse does this got then I'm on
stage having like a lackluster set being
like yeah trying to make this funny and
the crowds like me non-dance funny I'm
like what's wrong with you why are you
out [ __ ] Thanksgiving Ridgewell it
you read well it mm what's that route
wait who does that
um it's it's uh Ruby Tuesday's oh yeah
wait is it reads well it
yum that was Ruby Tuesday's that's the
contempt yeah
Red Robin yeah that is a contempt that
Red Robin has for the people that eat in
their restaurants the utter contempt
they have like they didn't even come up
with a word as much as it's just a shout
Red Robin YUM
cuz they're like they're like what are
the chances that anybody who would come
to our restaurant needs a multi-word
pitch to come in here let's just keep it
simple
Red Robin YUM mmm and if you go to Red
Robin lemme tell you it is not YUM
it is more like this Red Robin oh that's
really what it is Red Robin but I'll
tell you what is not uh and that's our
friends over the great Ridge wallet many
of you still have old leather daddy
wallets like big old fat catcher's mitts
you pull out of your pocket you got
everything falling out of there you got
mail you got business cards or people
that have tried to [ __ ] you over in the
past you got credit cards and debit
cards and you know they're all maxed out
you know god only knows which ones are
even still good and you just throw them
at waiters it you know Red Robin and uh
what you need to do is streamline it you
need to focus you need to start
eliminating the waste you don't need it
anymore you don't need the glutton so
rich wallet is a small front pocket
wallet very hard to lose metal wallet
you can't lose cash can't lose cards
it's all snapped into the ridge wallet
smart sleek sexy it's it's basically a
wallet that makes you boil down your
entire wallet and what you carry around
to sum a few essential things some cash
a few credit cards business card or to
keep it simple
nobody likes orders okay boomer okay
boomer YUM nobody wants hoarders people
want the the the the richest people I
know you go to their houses it's like
they don't even live there clean
surfaces are clear of any clutter and it
starts in your wallet it starts in your
pocket if you want to live like that it
starts in your pocket you pull out the
ridge
you know automatically you are protected
you're not going to lose your stuff and
you know that you have a wallet that is
going to be you know it's not obtrusive
it isn't one of these wallets that when
you pull out you feel gross you feel
good
it's available in really a bunch of
different colors which is great and go
out and get it if you love the show and
you don't like your wallet you want to
support the show it's a great
way and it's great wallet they've got
over 30,000 36,000 you know five-star
ratings and reviews on Yelp and
everything like that people really enjoy
the wallet if you don't like it they'll
take it back this is how confident they
are in the actual wallet they just
really love it so get 10% off today with
free worldwide shipping and returns
Ridge comm / Tim Ridge comm use code t
IM tell you right now folks it's a great
wallet and they respect you you know
they don't have a slogan like yum red
rubbin mmm
imagine saying this to somebody like
imagine saying is good looking at
somebody going let's go - lets get you
want to go to Red Robin I get if you
have to you're in a pinch you're in a
situation but can you imagine just
looking somebody going hey you wanted a
Red Robin let's go to Red Robin tonight
I'm really excited to try their new line
of burgers over at Red Robin you move
this way need a reg wallet a Ridge
wallet is like a Starbucks it's like
sleek boom in and out BAM get what you
need get that coffee get that caffeine
get out of there you know it's important
it's important you should you know the
phone and the wallet you got to really
update yourself Ridge is a great way to
you know look get into the new [ __ ] it
what is it the 21st century get into the
21st century I don't know what we're in
anymore I don't care
20th century 21st Center though we're in
the 22nd century I don't know it doesn't
matter to me until the same [ __ ] century
was but I'm telling you it's a good
thing to have it shows that you're
modern it shows you you're aware you
have a Ridge wallet maybe you could
start a cool conversation with somebody
like yeah how do you find out about the
bridge well it got me huge fan of the
podcast - Tim Dylan shall you start
talking about that you know maybe you
tell you meet your wife
very possibly how you meet your wife
she's like I love the Tim Dylan show
you're like [ __ ] that's a red flag
maybe yeah really
and she looks eating she goes YUM you go
okay but that's it's a conversation
starter the ridge it's interesting been
has one I have one it's great everybody
everybody's doing good so don't don't
[ __ ] around out there
go and get the ridge you go to Ridge
calm slash Tim ti em that's it and what
do you get Benjamin Tillman again tell
them what they get Benjamin you get 10%
off today if you don't like it it's free
worldwide shipping and returns so what
do you have to lose you have a horribly
annoying voice I'll say it again 10% off
free worldwide shipping and returns well
you gots Ben is so Ben we talked to him
does another voice and it gets on the
head okay yeah it's like what's wrong
with you
Ridge wallet
here's another thing folks um I watched
the Irishman does anyone in this
business die does anyone walk the [ __ ]
away when they need can you just get up
and walk away from the table I know
they're all legends I know they've done
a million things but that movie sucks it
is boring and it sucks and I love
everybody out on social media like
defending its honor it's all these
people that are in love with the past
and they can't let it [ __ ] go and
it's never the people that live through
it it's never the people who are like
actually there it's like [ __ ] people
that I like idolize mobsters even though
they work at Geico and they have no
[ __ ] idea and they think in their in
their lurid imaginations they run some
card game with Jimmy and Nicki and these
people just [ __ ] they love the past
and you're like I hate all the new
movies I'm not gonna I don't like them
they're all about babies all these do
movies are about babies they're about
Jenna I like when men were men
you know and that people used to smoke
and smack women in the face you know
it's such a [ __ ] first of all the the
first scene of the movie they're all CGI
because they're all the the so these so
these are all older actors like Pesci
and De Niro and they CGI them to make
them look younger
so you it's just a bunch of CGI corpses
for the first thing in the movie I know
so many talented people that can't
afford water and and it's just the same
people over and over again it's like you
you couldn't make a mob move you
couldn't make this movement but the
whole thing is it's just a [ __ ] money
grab they're like well it Scorsese we're
gonna make it with Keitel and De Niro
and Pacino and Pesci and they're all old
and it's like it's just not good its
drawn-out its long and and people are
just [ __ ] you know and now people are
getting really testy about it like
people are adopting the Irishman as like
you know this they're like it's a
masterpiece
these are legends and oh you don't like
it because what it's so you don't like
it cuz you're a [ __ ] were you cat videos
you don't like the Irishman it's a guy's
it we saw it already it was called
Goodfellas it was better it was shorter
there's a movie called Hoffa right we
saw that we did it we've done with these
kind of movies where it's like a
narrator is explaining like hey this is
tall you know the first time I met Tony
I was at the speak it's and good for
Sebastian and Jim Norton guys that I
think are amazing they're in it great
but it's just like let's move the [ __ ]
on let's stop and I see these people on
social media that are really that are
really loving the movie and it's you
know it's not like it's people that like
think that if they were alive in that
time they'd be like part of the Rat Pack
that's like no you wouldn't be part of
the Rat Pack you'd be a guy who one of
these guys would embarrass and like hit
in the back of the head with a butt of a
gun
so this fantasy land you live in where
you think you're like you know you think
you're Dean Martin it's not the case
it's a boring [ __ ] movie and
people it like he can't can't understand
or appreciate that we've moved the [ __ ]
on we've moved on from this enough
already
I'll like it cuz it's towards the whole
world and you see the way that the
people used to be into all their legends
no smoking jackets and Cadillacs shut
the [ __ ] up
go back to your cubicle at Geico enough
you [ __ ] clown you think you're some
[ __ ] Vegas mobster some [ __ ] you're
you'll could not to guys you know could
look to god this is such a Long Island
[ __ ] Jersey movie a bunch of [ __ ]
people that think they're connected to
the Mafia because they're dumb uncle
went to jail once cuz he was used as a
[ __ ] patsy and they think there's
somehow in the mob and they all [ __ ]
have you know Goodfellas and Scarface
posters on their room on their walls and
you're 38 years old they live with their
mother and they waiting for her to fall
down the stairs so they can inherit a
[ __ ] house and they think they're
like Jimmy Hoffa they think they're like
a real Street guy you know all the
Irishmen so it's great movies you know
you're my cousin you're all because this
is one of those movies where like
everybody will tell they're like I grew
up in a town with legit mafia people and
that and it yet inform that the way I
grew up to an extent but it's like I
don't romanticize any of that horseshit
it's cool the food was good but it's
like why can't we stop you cut it out
please
you're a [ __ ] grown-up enough with
the plate I'm like you [ __ ] have any
clue the Irishman seven hours I showered
in the middle of it I didn't even stop
it I showered I did launch ready it was
in and out of the room it's so long it's
so long and then they have the scene
where it's not a scene but it's like the
after thing with Scorsese and they're
all talking about like making the movie
and stuff like that it's like Scorsese
how about stepping out of your [ __ ]
comfort zone make a movie about about
black trans women
why don't you impress me stop making
movies about these [ __ ] goons we get
it how about you show that you got a
little
[ __ ] range make him make a movie
about babies who grow up to be gangsters
I mean enough already
I did dentist so I've talked about on
the show life in the big city love these
movies he loved those and I get it cuz
they had a place and he grew up and he
knew the guys and he knew the plays he
knew it he knew Henry Hill he knew those
guys they lived in a town that I grew up
but the people that are really
identifying what the Irishmen are not
people that had any [ __ ] clue what
was going on during that time at all
they did nothing no [ __ ] idea
they just romanticize it because they
think that if they had lived then boy
would have been real real real different
you know they would have been really
[ __ ] running the show they'd be
really running the table you know little
insane I just see all these people go oh
yeah old these people don't like the
Irish yeah it's an objectively bad movie
it's boring it's objectively bad have
you seen it yeah yeah it's such a waste
for people like a pest she came out of
retirement it's like no he should have
stayed in it he did the right thing go
go back to retirement and let somebody
else have a shot let someone have a
chance let somebody else please have a
chance please we don't need this what
are we gonna be doing we're gonna are we
gonna just animate their dead bodies is
that gonna be the next movie that we
make when they when they're literally
dead i I don't understand they're all on
death's door they've had great lives and
great careers they've done amazing
things let them be nobody needs this but
it is it's a big moneymaker because it's
the boomers love it mmm-hmm boomers love
it so whatever that's my piece on the
Irishman I know that people give me flak
for that and I know people get angry it
did well would it make 140 mil well
that's the budget that's the budget it
was a hundred for
million dollars Jesus that was all spent
a colostomy bags for the talent so they
could piss themselves and they don't
have to stop filming you know enough
already not enough these [ __ ] people
you know it's you go on social media
it's the same people
it's like Suzy better dad I was like I
love the Irishman it's such a great
that's when things made sense yeah did
they did they how about you gonna make a
lasagna you neanderthal
I bet you go it does it does make sense
I'd like those yeah you that time when
women were not on Facebook they were
making ravioli so go back to that how
about you follow the example of the
Irishman and shut the [ __ ] up and get
back in the kitchen if you like that
time so much how about you follow the
rules and stop opining about culture we
don't need it Mary Ann we don't need it
don't make a meatloaf I just you know
it's this the people are like nostalgic
for periods of time that they didn't
even [ __ ] live through this 1950s
horseshit where everything was so good
but we were you know siccing dogs on
black kids trying to go to school you
know like well what did I get it
modernity sucks it has its problems but
let's stop jerking off the past every
[ __ ] it's the sign of a dead society
that were jerking the past off all the
time and can someone show up to the new
set of Mad About You with a gun and tell
Paul Reiser and Helen Hunt that have
enough [ __ ] money that nobody Marie's
dead the dogs dead nobody needs that
[ __ ] show again that wasn't good when it
was on the air mad about you how empty
are people's lives that they need this
[ __ ]
well what's Frasier Crane been doing
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you get a
life these people who is this for Disney
Plus
are you doing watching The Little
Mermaid you're a 38 year old man stop
reading Harry Potter in public you're an
adult enough I mean this this Disney
Plus lunacy
if you have kids and you want to show
them these things I get it but you know
the amount of it
you know Jared Logan had a great point
he's like Disney is the first culture
you're exposed to it's not supposed to
be the last you're not supposed to go
well I'm just gonna stay here all those
movies I saw when I was three that's
where I'll stay I just want to watch the
Lion King on loop when I was on the tour
bus I had these couple that came on my
tour bus they hated New York City they
really didn't like it New York's not for
everyone but you know this woman and her
husband they hated New York City they
were to you know blobs and they came in
and they sat down and they had disney
shirts on and they go you know we were
gonna take a Disney cruise we take a
Disney cruise every year but this time
we decided to go to New York and they go
we just we didn't really like it we
didn't enjoy it they go the one thing we
did enjoy was the Lion King they go we
saw the Lion King play and that was nice
we don't like anything else we we just
don't like it we don't you know and I'm
like whoa they go we just want to go to
Disney World and I said well why do you
like this new world and they go well
it's just the best place on earth you
don't have any responsibilities I'm like
but that's not life right I mean I said
to them I go well that's not life right
I mean that's for children children have
no responsibilities because they're
children
but you're adults right so no matter
where you are you have some
responsibilities right and they're like
well no you know Disney World you're
just totally you know you have no
responsibility just it's the best play
Center and like you could say you could
tell that like every question I asked
was making them angrier because I was
like I was it was an assault to them
because they were very happy in their
living coma and they just wanted they
were just like no I just want to be
taking pictures with Mickey on the
Disney cruise you know you could tell
this was a couple that like held hands
that had never seen each other's
genitals and you know had probably you
know it's sick it's a sickness this is a
disease Disney is a disease it's enough
and they suck these movies don't hold up
I tried to watch lady in the [ __ ] the
other day
sucks and it used to be great but you
know why was a kid
it doesn't really hold on I do like the
Siamese cat scene that is good still
because I like them and I like the way
that they kind of you know that I like
um that holds up certain films do hold
up song of the south holds up that is a
really that's a joke that's a joke
everyone
don't get excited put the torch down put
the torch down put your citronella
candle out don't get it too excited just
kidding it's comedy
I just kept tweeting yesterday funny
things and so many people thought I was
here like I tweeted I said you know we
let my six-year-old cousins say grace
and he came out as the non-binary and he
told call my grandfather a colonizing
Pig fun start to dinner and then there
were people that are like who was put up
to like they don't they can't read that
I'm a comedian on Twitter they not there
like he was put up to this no six year
old I'm like out Jesus Christ people
can't get a joke I said one I said some
of the tweets really funny I go I said
like I said you know my aunt my uncle
I'll just I'll just I'll read some of
these tweets because the amount of
people that thought they were real
tweets and then you know we're attacking
me going I don't believe you or you know
some of those people are trolls but some
of them legitimately they're like they
they literally think that I'm literally
you know talking about real things it
happened okay quick update on holiday my
grandmother just called a restaurant
oriental and now we're beating the [ __ ]
out of you now we're beating the [ __ ]
out of her and then people were like
responding to that there was one where I
said wow this got awkward real quick my
aunt and uncle who her brother and
sister are full-on [ __ ] in the living
room and we're all pretending they left
to get beer this is a wild one lol we're
never gonna let them live this down
the six-year-old cousin one was great I
just loved some of the responses yeah it
was a setup the parents were involved
colonizing are you British it's great
it's great go to that let's find the
yeah listen to this this is disrespect
is rampant in today's youth more so than
any other time it's a direct reflection
of the failure that is today's parenting
my son would have would have his lips
slapped off if he talked to his
grandfather that way 12 likes on that
response that's a guy with a great sense
of humor and then you read these
responses and you go oh no it's not
gonna be okay
we're not gonna find this political
solution to whatever these issues are
because that's the public that's John Q
public those are the people out there
that you're gonna have to convince of
the things that you want to do those are
the people the people that are
responding to my clear what was clearly
a joke in a very serious way support for
the Tim Dylan show comes from manscape
and from viewers like you
let's remember that from like PBS from
your kid oh yeah yeah you know channel
13 they would do those drives and they'd
be like support for the children's
public television network comes from the
Helena Rubinstein foundation Halliburton
you know Raytheon is true as all defense
contractors and viewers like you
manscaped is the best in men's
below-the-belt grooming it offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels tools for the jewels
jingle balls to the walls fellas listen
up untrimmed pubes or a thing of the
past
nobody likes a big [ __ ] bush that you
haven't taken the time to [ __ ] scape
it's time to gear up and get yourself
the gift of Shaving I'm talking about
the man's cape perfect package 2.0 you
know what's great about manscaped is you
need this product it's not something you
don't need you need to clean it up down
there the only other product on the
market is in a relic a body groom it's
false this one is far superior to that
the lawnmower 2.0 comes inside of their
perfect package which makes the perfect
gift this holiday season it's everything
you need to be trimmed cut for
smelling nice have a ball deodorizer all
kinds of things the crop preserver and
answer chafing moisturizer I'm telling
you it's it's the move if you want to
clean up your junk
it's the move you gotta have a nice
situation down there it's good for
everybody involved you know are these
these products smell good they're manly
scent is attractive and will help set
the mood if you know what I mean I love
that they say if you know what I mean
because it's like well the whole thing
is about balls and sex was like when
they're like if you know what I'm is
like they're being coy with that one
line like if you know what we mean yeah
we do know what you mean the whole
[ __ ] ad is about getting your trunk
ready to [ __ ] that's the whole point or
just to have a nice job who knows
perfect package comes with a pair of
manscaped boxer briefs that will keep
your junk feeling fresh all day it's
time to upgrade those over the over use
pair of used boxers to manscape
high-performance anti chafing boxer
briefs high-performance have you used
the hype the the lawn mower I used it I
liked it I liked it a lot I didn't it
didn't clip me anywhere and correctly
because I've tried to use a beard
trimmer down there and it's just too
rough and yeah this this lawn mower it
really gets the [ __ ] job done down
there I used it the other day and I and
I cut my dick off I emailed I emailed
manscape and I said we got a big problem
here and I told them the whole story and
then they emailed me back and they were
like we'll send you a free ball to
notarize this all right fine I still got
those I'm kidding folks
what's good about manscaped is you don't
cut your dick off a lot of these things
you know sometimes before you hook up
with somebody you just try to get your
dick ready and you try to just shave
your area and you're doing it very quick
and there's a lot of pressure you know
and it's like Ben has one girlfriend so
it's kind of different when you just
have one girlfriend you've had forever
they're like frontier people they're
like Oregon Trail relationship you know
just travel around the country in a
wagon and all the kids have got a
smallpox but like the rest of you you're
out there you meet new people and they
haven't seen your dick before so you
want to give it the bet you want to give
it the old you know you want it to feel
nice that's reality tis the season to
manscape so get yourself your dad your
brother and your friends and you know
all shave your [ __ ] together shave take
your dicks out Christmas and manscape
there's nothing get listen there is
nothing remotely homosexual about
shaving your dick with your dad and your
brothers over the holidays there's
nothing you shouldn't feel any way about
call your best friend to go why don't
you come over here and let's shave each
other's dicks let's shave each other's
balls with man with man escapes it's
about cement spread have yo do you get
here and you I get here my dick you have
to shave the actual shaft yeah because
it creeps up the deck mm-hmm yeah well
well this is a good situation listen you
tell you get your father a manscaped
it's fun you know you say dad you can
put a clean your junk up okay boomer say
that write to your father
shave your [ __ ] at the holiday table
front everyone why not start with the
toxic masculinity of not shaving your
dick in front of your friends and your
male relatives it's toxic masculinity
man I have parties I've manscape parties
call bunch of buddies and go hey we're
all gonna put a bucket in the middle of
the room to collect everybody's pubes
and then remember that thing that was
like a it was a remember was like is
some type of dumb toy where you took a
magnet and you dragged a little fur to
the guy's mustache it was like that dumb
little face he was magnetic and you
would you take a little magnet you would
like drag the hair
to the beard oh yeah there it is like
single again this thing what's it called
the play monster wooly Willy yeah things
like that so you just you tell your
buddies you go let's go let's have a
woolly woolly woolly Willy party and I
go what do you mean you gots a wooly
Willy party we all shave each other's
dicks we collect the pubes in a bucket
in the middle of the room and then we
have little magnet faces and we make we
make beards with everyone's pubes your
balls will thank you get 20% off free
shipping with the coat empty IM at
manscape calm manscape calm the code is
t IM here's a reality folks you need the
manscape er what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do out there well I'm
literally asking what are you gonna do
you gotta get it together you gotta
shave that area so what are you gonna do
you gonna get - Darrell Coe my body
groom that's owned by Gillette it's
owned by Ira Rennert there's got the the
most he's got the largest private
residence in the world in Sagaponack New
York no how about you help me out
IRA run it's fine I don't even know if
he's still alive
he's got the biggest house in the whole
[ __ ] country
he owns Gillette isn't a relic Oh on
budget you're let get it get a [ __ ]
groomer maybe not the point is this
whoever owns New Relic oh is also doing
better than me okay so by the manscaped
and man skate with your friends you know
that's the type of Christian [ __ ] that
you're afraid of because you're raised
in a very small minded environment when
nobody's shaved their [ __ ] together but
that be the best thing in the world for
you is next Christmas everybody to shave
their balls and deodorize each other's
balls we're gonna do dereyes everyone's
balls before dinner are your balls
deodorized if not you're not coming into
my house don't use the same trimmer on
your face as you use on your balls
that's just nasty Ness Ness key basket
like some southern some swamp person
don't use the same trimmer
that's nice key that's a white voice I'm
doing that's a southern white person I
am thankful for their crop revive this
product along with the crop preserver
keeps your balls from sticking to your
leg okay so we have an ashtray here
please what am i living like some less
than [ __ ] pig this is great now he's
going to get a [ __ ] ashtray
three flights up you know this is this
is what you do you get the help you
cannot afford manscape comm where'd you
get that from manscape comm Tim get the
crop retriever and the ball replacer and
whatever it is got the what get the crop
circles and the [ __ ] the tan tied
chafing which and then there get the
[ __ ] Alexa get it all get it all folks
buy it all one for six easy payments of
$79.99 you can see your dick and if
you're if you're a little overweight you
know you won't you need every inch so
what you do is you don't need that inch
of pubes you get that out of there
Ben's skinny and he always says he talks
about his big dick it's like you know
this these are there are people that
have not seen their penis in years and
you got a and you because they're not
taking proper care it's like the secret
garden down there they don't know what's
going on
so get it get the [ __ ] trimmer and the
beard trimmer and the the crop circle
you know get it all buy it all don't
start with me Red Robin yo Thank You
manscape calm promo code Tim um some
some people found Lisa's lounge you said
on yeah let me pull that up on
TripAdvisor I love that by the way
TripAdvisor is a site the idea that the
bar that I used to get drunk in and
throw my that that many people have
thrown their lives away and lisas lounge
in Long Island the fact that anyone
raided it on Trip Advisor that someone
took a trip and thought it was
appropriate to rate Lisa's lounge to me
like imagine being that person
imagine stumbling into a corner bar and
then going home and writing a paragraph
about it right love I like by the way
how many reviews on TripAdvisor doesn't
have only two
what a strange spooky night when here
some years back to see a rather awful
ban truthfully our pet well by the way
I've never seen a band there I have no
idea there's no place for anyone to play
there's really no place for anyone to
play music but they go they go
our pal was filling in with them place
was completely empty for Saturday night
every 20 minutes there were equipment
failures one old guy at the bar and a
very nervous bartender because they're
they're doing coke place was icy cold in
spots in the bathroom you felt like
somebody was watching you after a while
we went and then so then they go down
and they go oh we were told that a guy
was shot outside two people were shot
outside we called the double homicide
that was a nickname of the place and the
poor guys body was dragged out the back
door as the cops ambulance arrived out
of there and no we never returned
although the drinks food were good they
don't serve food so this is how like
people are out just still out of it and
then the next one go down to the next
one the next one goes not your normal
neighborhood place I don't know if they
serve food here but the place is dirty
I'll never go back dive bar real dive
bar you didn't get it that it was called
Lisa's lounge and it was
on the corner in a residential area it's
clearly not a destination spot you know
I love Pam this place was dirty I'll
never go back that's the point go to
Yelp see if they have anything up on
yoga I love Lisa's lounge and I spent
Christmas in Lisa's lounge and I don't
regret it at all it was a lot funner
than being at that goddamn [ __ ] Mason
Lodge wherever the [ __ ] I wasn't Malibu
and it was you know Lisa's lounge is fun
there was about four or five people
there on Christmas Eve and me and my
friend Joe had a great [ __ ] time
Lisa's Lodge three reviews on Yelp
let's see upon coming back this is a
hidden gem really there's a pool table
and a nice staff if you're a veteran
there will oblige you to a free beer
they're nice stop by sometime at this
nice little dive that's sweet
good here's another one decent little
dive bar and bald a nice cozy good crowd
close to home well not a NAT triplet
stop for a drink after lunch with a
girlfriend and see the lovely Erica
bartending I had a shrimp out of her
mouth once it was a dare and I was drunk
we were also pleasantly surprised to see
the bar nicely decorated for Christmas
it's really nice on Christmas it really
is nice they really deck it out they put
lights all over the place it really is a
nice Christmas if you want to make a
nice Christmas memory there was a woman
named Marge once Marge used to come in
and shoot herself marge was an old woman
and she would come in the bar and she
would buy everyone drinks she'd go give
the boys the boys another round on me
and then her daughter would show up and
have to take her out of there because
she would get and and it went once she
[ __ ] herself and then everybody the bar
started laughing you know like we think
Marge [ __ ] herself and she was like
she's like she's she's like we were
obviously not saying it to her face she
was a elderly woman but she just started
screaming the top of her lungs she goes
she goes are you laughing at me [ __ ]
I just bought you a bunch of drinks and
you're laughing at me [ __ ] she goes I
should have my husband come down here
and kick your ass
dad years ago so our daughter comes in
here and her daughter's like mom you
[ __ ] yourself and so they carry Marg out
and as they're carrying her out she's
literally screaming it's not for a long
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] she's just
screaming fake which is why you can't
really get rid of the word [ __ ]
because it was at that moment there's
really no other appropriate word for
Marg to use because she was angry she
just said her [ __ ] herself she had spent
a year she spent years and years and
years of her life just imbibing alcohol
and you know and at that moment I guess
she could have yelled the n-word but we
were all white that would have been
awkward also funny but it was a perfect
word I thought you never go up to gay
person and say hey that's [ __ ] up but
Marge yelling [ __ ] with it with it
with a with her her pants full of [ __ ]
as as her daughter and two guys had to
walk her out of the bar to me is
appropriate and I would like to sit down
with any of these kids at Oberlin or
Wesleyan and explain to them
well what word should Marge have used at
that particular juncture she had bought
us drinks it was somewhat cruel of us to
laugh at her after she [ __ ] her I mean
it was we were kind of being [ __ ] I
guess we should have just quietly but we
were just laughing you know we were kind
of being [ __ ] about the whole thing
and there didn't seem an appropriate
word for Marge to use as she was carried
out of Lisa's loud I think for the last
time I don't think she ever came back
there note I believe this is a cash bar
only a good place for friends to hang
out we'll definitely return quiet townie
bar drinks are cheap love a good local
dive when I told my father I was hanging
out here instead of my dad being like oh
you have a problem we should put you in
a home or we should put you in rehab
he's like you know he looked at me goes
son such a bloomer response he goes you
know son a like a dirtbag bar has played
a role in every Dylan's life your uncle
Tommy had a place called Buckley's I
used to go to a place called my father's
place like he would just you know and
I'm like great it says this is good you
know it's like son you're you're
following a long tradition of people
that have made very bad choices in a
very similar way to the ones you're
making
right now Lisa's lounge if you're in
Baldwin Long Island stop in and have a
pop have a cocktail many of the people I
know are dead that you know I brought
did you come in there with me yeah we
went back but I don't think you
recognized anybody right no because
remember there was like a bunch of
pictures on the wall of the people that
are now dead yeah and you're like
whatever happened to Trevor and you're
like they were like yeah throat cancer
when a year Susu died yeah
they lived hard these people lived very
hard they they really didn't take care
of themselves um many of them chose the
bar over their families and their you
know it was you know alcoholism is very
tough
that being said um it was a lot of fun
there was a time there when we had a
really good time when you just say to
yourself let's just make the best of it
every now and then somebody would
stumble into that bar didn't know what
it was about it was a place where you
were you were unable to enjoy it
ironically which is great like you know
every now and then like you'd see a
hipster piece of [ __ ] walk in and try to
like enjoy it ironically but you
couldn't do that because it was like
there was a woman Janna used to hang out
there and she had that she had those
diabetic shoes those big shoes and she
would walk in and she was in a she was
in a group home but she would get a day
pass and then she would go out to Lisa's
lounge and she was ill she was mentally
ill so again you'd feel uncomfortable
automat like immediately if you came in
there to just like God such a dirty
little dive bar I'm just gonna go in and
have a little drink immediately you
would you would be like oh this is
really bad because all the horrors of
the world were on full display as they
should have been like Jen for example
one day Jen came in there was a newer
bartender and this was a great story Jen
came in I was there and the newer
bartender was there and Jen walked in
and Jen goes I'm having a party for the
fire department here tonight
I need chafing dishes out I need [ __ ]
I need you to be ready and the bartender
was like okay all right
and and I was just sitting there at me
and a few other people were sitting
there were all just kind of smiling
weren't really saying anything and you
know Jen walked in and she goes we're
having that we're having a party for the
fire department they're all coming here
tonight the bartender was like okay that
seems strange but hey it's a local bar
this is what local bars do they support
the local you know first responders okay
so Jen set up all the chafing dishes and
of course the food never came because
there was no food and then the
firefighters never came because that was
also not real but Jen just got bombed
and played pool by herself and played
music from the jukebox and didn't seem
to mind that nope not nobody was
actually there
she didn't address it she never brought
it up and nobody brought it up and and
then the bartender just obviously
stopped asking when they were arriving
because she realized pretty quickly that
Jen was mentally ill and in Jen's mine
the bar was full of firefighters and she
was having a great time and and throwing
a party so it wasn't a place where like
you could like go and you had to be down
with that you had to be down with
drinking with crazy Jen you had to be
death or crazy patty who came and crazy
patty had done some time in jail because
she'd carved up another woman's face
when they were children for maybe a man
I forget but patty my grandmother taught
patty it's like fourth grade or
something patty had and Patty son called
her Watson me my friends over there when
Patty son called her and Patty son was
like mom and we heard we heard him say
over the phone to mama in Vegas I think
I took too much of something mom I'm in
Vegas I think I took too much and she
just looked and she goes all right honey
I'll see you later and just hung up the
phone and then me her and my friend Joe
did shots you know you had to be okay
with that if you weren't okay with if
you were gonna be the type of person
that said is your son okay you would
have to leave you would have to leave at
that point if you couldn't enjoy or just
at least
make peace with the fact that you know
this was the way it was you sure like
you know all these speakeasies like
these bars they try to market themselves
as speakeasies and all these [ __ ] you
know young professional Millennials go
there and they're like ooh this is what
it was like to drink bathtub gin yeah
you know you know Lisa's lounge was it
was a real horror show it was a real Rob
Zombie movie and you had to be okay with
that and we were okay I was okay with it
didn't I didn't mind you know my friend
Julie who I brought to Lisa's loud she
lived next my friend Joe and I said hi
Julie how are you what happened you know
what I don't know why I asked her what
how could she said my husband's in jail
and I said well what happened she goes
well let me give you the Reader's Digest
version and I said okay and she goes he
came home one night he was really on a
bender he tried to kill me and then the
cops got him three houses away it was
covered in my blood if that bothered you
you couldn't hang out there you had to
say well I'm glad things are going well
today would you like a shot and she
always would want a shot she was a fun
woman and you just had to be okay with
that but then every now and then there'd
be people that would stumble in because
they thought that it was like a fun
little divey bar for them to like you
know just kind of ironically enjoy
but you couldn't ironically enjoy it
because you were surrounded by people
who are dead serious
like it wasn't a crowd of people like
these were people that were dead serious
there was a guy named Bobby and his wife
Sally and she would spit a sheer quill
or some drug into his beer every night
so he would literally pass out and
that's the only way she could drag him
out of the bar that he would wake up the
next day is she had to drug him every
night and you would have to witness that
and go okay okay that's the way they
live you know he choked once and Sally
looked so happy because he was about to
die literally his name is Bobby ha ha he
was like 50 but he looked 90 and he you
got a laugh like this you go and he had
the glass he had the glass shop next to
the bar
and every night then he laughs you know
that's how he last we couldn't Bobby hi
and one night he almost died and I mean
literally I've never seen someone choke
to the point where their air their air
was literally blocked but he was so
beet-red and it was at the point was no
longer choking he just started and
everyone at the bar was just kind of
watching Sally was just like all right
he's done now I guess and then the
bartender came up to his bartender Tracy
and he goes he finally I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened I think somebody
smacked him on his back or whatever and
he just coughed up this like chicken
wing this chunk of meat they'd been
choking on and as soon as he got enough
air he went I guess he went I started
laughing and Tracy goes Bobby are you
okay and he looked at her you got a fast
now that was disturbing for a lot of
people people couldn't have fun in that
environment a lot of people couldn't
have fun in that environment but I
always thought it was fun and
challenging it's challenging morally was
that the same crowd at the helm
yeah well the crowd at the helm the helm
was an old fisherman bar and the helm
had been around since like the 60s or
70s and the helm had been flooded so
many times the the the floor was kind of
warped the wood had been worn um the
helmet the best cheeseburger I've ever
had it's still the best cheeseburger
I've ever had and I always wondered why
I think it's cuz they never cleaned the
grill I asked a guy once he said why is
his burger the best he's like because
it's 3 a.m. and we're drunk and I was
like well that might be it but it was
really a great burger if you're ever in
Freeport I don't know if it's the same
go to the bar get the burger American
cheese sautéed onions it's great the
helm the helm had a very similar there
was a guy named Lou at the helm oh hang
out who didn't have a nose set a hole in
the middle of his face he snorted his
nose off it was the same type of people
but the helm was a little people would
more people could kind of go to the helm
and enjoy it because it was on the water
but not many of them like you know we're
talking about
we're talking about like the difference
between a person that's a lifer at a bar
like this and a casual and at least it
was very hard to be a casual you know
you really have to just resign yourself
to what Lisa's lounge was the power of
the lounge I just used took my friends
would call me think oh where are you I'm
at the lounge and then they would come
and my friends would always come and
enjoy because I mean they're dirtbags my
friends would dirtbags I love them all
but they were dirtbags so that's why
they liked it they thought it was great
but every now and then the hell you know
the hell might get some people in there
that were not that were just you know
not aware of what it was and might have
a drink you know on a Friday night at 6
p.m. and then leave and then go to
dinner and not really get it but the
helm really came alive you know around
you know midnight when it was just the
people that really belonged there and
you know Joan who's a great bartender
Joanie either were fights at the helm
people smash glasses over each other's
heads it was you know this is that type
of place it was just you know it was
that type of crew but a great burger and
many people have never spent any time in
these bars
they've never spent time in bars like
this you know like Ryan what's his name
Philippi Philippe how do you pronounce
that name I am Not sure he comma diddid
that he liked the last episode I don't
know if he listens a lot or he lives
like a guy like that - probably not
spent a ton of time in bars like this
you know like he you know a guy that's a
good like a good looking Hollywood actor
yeah he's probably not spent an
inordinate amount of time and I'm in
these blood boxes nor should he have I
can see now this is this is you know but
it's like there are people out there
that just never true and some of them
will just go to a bar like this once and
they don't they don't just settle into
it and become a regular to be a regular
at a bar like this changes you a little
bit because you know when I was growing
up like the thing about when I was
growing up and doing a lot of drugs
you would
like the type of poverty I saw had a lot
to do with drugs like the people that
didn't have money or they didn't have
and I'm not saying all poverty has to do
with that most of it does not say don't
[ __ ] yeah tell me I'm saying that
what I because I was druggie the
situations that I got myself into and
you know when I would see when I would
go and hang out at you know crack house
whatever you wanna call it a house where
they were selling cocaine and you know
three or four families were living in
this little house and you know it was
largely drugs and people just didn't
have good jobs and they weren't saving
for their retirement you know and none
of that was hat because they were on
drugs they were selling drugs they were
they were you know going out with
somebody who sold drugs this is how they
were earning a living it's how they were
making money and and of course there
were you know people you know you and
there were kids around and it was shitty
it was sad because a lot of those a lot
of those kids you know would bother you
they would just bought we were all
trying to do drugs and a lot of these
kids would just bother you all the time
because every children very selfish but
it was also sad that you know they
weren't gonna have a shot at life blah
blah blah but it is very I didn't do it
but you would feel bad you'd feel
morally like oh because you'd be doing
coke in a room and then in another room
like somebody had a baby and you're like
oh that baby is not gonna have a lot of
advantages that that baby should have
you know I mean it's just so when you
become a regular at these bars you you
really see you want to talk about like
the middle class you see what happens
when people don't have a career when
they have a job and when they don't make
enough money and they don't have a
stable living situation and they don't
have any community of people they find a
community and they're also an alcoholic
the community becomes the bar they go
out to the bar they network at the bar
if somebody needs somebody to help them
with something if they need an apartment
they ask around at the bar this becomes
their
you know so being in these you know bars
and spending time there are kind of
becoming a regular there I would see
that and I myself you know would you
know I'd be like hey you got a guy for
this you know somebody does this it was
like these were people that you know
unfortunately some of them had kids some
of the midwives but this is you know the
choice that they made they they just
spent a lot of time and their entire
life revolved around their addiction and
their addiction their addictions you
know destroyed their lives and they
destroyed their families and they
destroyed their careers and they destroy
their communities and not unless you're
a regular at a place like that unless
you see people over a span of time it's
hard to understand that but it does give
you kind of a good and I was doing it
myself in any of these people I was
doing the same [ __ ] thing all right a
house I couldn't afford he's being
rapidly foreclosed on I was not out of
the closet yet I wasn't dating anybody I
was in my life shocked I was just going
to this you know decrepit mortgage
office every day and then what was it
doing every single night I talk to my
friends about it they were like yeah we
just figured you were like figuring
things out I was like oh good yeah
that's what was going on and I'm and I
was in a way but you know I was there
every single night I was twenty [ __ ]
three years old 23 24 you know I meet
young people that are young and they're
they're happy and they got chacón for
them they're the truant whatever it were
whatever it is you know you know I was
22 or 23 living the life of a 50 year
old guy going to a dirtbag bar every
night and just getting [ __ ] hammered
and you know and but being a regular at
a place like that really kind of gives
you a perspective on how easy it is to
fall into a bad community you know if
you grow up in the projects and you have
to join a gang for safety or whatever
you know you understand how people end
up in a situation they shouldn't be in
and they don't leave because it becomes
you know who you these are other people
you associate with and these are the
people that you spend time with and
these are the people that
you know you commiserate with and these
are the you know you experience things
in this place you know you know the TV
was on at least his lounge and we would
see you know watch the Super Bowl or
whatever this is how they live this is
this was their life and there are people
who just never get out of that there are
people that never get out of that they
spend their entire life in a place like
that or they bounce from one at play and
then it's all the booze it's not because
Lisa's lounge is charming and fun and
quaint and kitschy and oh I love the guy
I love a corner bar like even the Yelp
reviews people like I love a dive bar I
love a corner dive bar it's like yep you
do cuz you don't know what's going on
there you haven't really appreciated you
haven't seen some kid walk in and try to
drag his parent his father out of there
because he's like we haven't seen you no
kidding is what mother would come in and
try to drag a dad out but are you gonna
come home here every night
so wouldn't you you know you haven't
seen that you haven't really gotten the
full picture of what a what a bar like
that is uh you know this is why I like
now I think about like one people don't
go out a lot anymore I mean they go out
you know everything's clean up people
out the clubs you had whatever I used to
go out to clubs I never was at home at a
club I've gone out to those you know New
York City night clubs you know when I
was doing mortgages and [ __ ] I never
felt at home there I never felt like I
belong to there I was there it was fun
it was a good time but these bars I felt
at home because I was just anesthetized
myself every night with [ __ ] booze
and I just wanted to drink and I met and
I really hung out there for a while like
you know I mean and we go back every
time you know when we go to New York
I'll bring I'll bring and this is my
friends don't like my friend Michael
that went to Thanksgiving with when I
brought him there is a but did you want
to get laid I don't understand there's
nobody and I'm like you don't get add
you don't get what it is when you're in
the throes of a really deep addiction
you just need booze I would just drink
kettle on the rocks every single night
and there'd be bugs in the glass and you
who gives a [ __ ] Tracy would pour some
cattle one out you just get [ __ ] up
every night and I would stumble back to
my house cuz I lived the block away and
that was that was my you know there was
no like it was it was there was no like
you know when I look back when I was
like a party or I look back it was like
it was there wasn't a party wasn't I
mean it was a party I was like in high
school
maybe a year into college you're a cop
but once I settled into just being a
degenerate alcoholic it was just a means
to an end of like this was a fun place
to get [ __ ] up where nobody would
judge you no matter what you had going
on you could just walk into this place
and get hammered and I was losing my
house and that was okay nobody cared
nobody really asked questions and if you
were like you know I'm losing my house
like somebody else at the bar would you
know razorsharp doesn't be like I've
lost my house so it's like oh good we
found each other this is a group this is
a community of people the Tim Dylan show
sponsored by can i progear the world is
going to hell in a handbasket you got to
be ready for battle and it starts with a
good backpack that's right [ __ ] the
transport okay get that NPR tote bag and
set it on fire get kunai ProGear their
backpacks are inspired by military
assault packs they took military grade
materials like 500d Cordura nylon the
brand name nylon don't you know which is
the strongest lightest and most durable
this thing were survived in Epstein's
cell boom lots of great products have
come out of the military aviator glasses
the Jeep Wrangler and now you can use
the phallic duty pack it's in use by the
US government if it's trusted by the
Secret Service agents it's good enough
for you all their backpacks are designed
with functionality in mind so whether
you're an anti feh your violent
communist or your neo-nazi whatever
works
you need a backpack government
demonstrations eco-terrorist you need a
backpack whatever you're trying to do
out there you know whether it's just
some small scale hitting somebody
disagree with with a brick or larger
scale trying to bring down local or
government agencies you are going to
need a backpack and it's got to be
durable because you're gonna take some
mace to the face and bike locks to the
head if you really believe in stuff and
we've been on reddit you people do so if
you really believe all this stuff you
got to go out there with pro gear you
got to really get ready for the beating
you're gonna take at the hands of the
corporate state now they are gonna win
at the end it's true they're gonna crush
you across your face right into that
dirt but you'll still have a nice
backpack and you'll meet some fun people
that's what it's really about anyway no
one has the illusion they're gonna win
you'll meet some fun people you know so
if you're gonna be one of the yellow
vests in France or one of the people who
got involved with the Arab Spring
whatever it is you got to get out there
and really show them who's boss you know
civil disobedience it's the only way to
really make a change and you gotta have
good gear okay nobody wants some [ __ ]
JanSport cloth backpack getting ripped
in the middle of a violent riot that
doesn't help anybody you need to stick
and move you know be quick you're gonna
be taking tear gas to the face and if
you do you need a backpack that you can
count on like can i Pro gear okay there
holiday sales are now my code TI em you
can get an additional 15% off okay t I
am getting a digital 15% off and for a
limited time if you spend over $40
you'll throw in free shipping
that's kunai Prager comm c-a-n-n-a EPR
OGE AR can I procure comm all their
products come with a lifetime warranty
no matter what happens out there rest
assured can I will repair or replace any
backpack as long as you walk the earth
so get the last backpack you'll ever buy
at kunai Pro gear.com here's a great
backpack I mean we have one they send us
all the products that we advertise it's
a great backpack it's a tough backpack
if you're a college student you need a
good backpack you know even if you're a
young adult you need a good backpack if
you're a filmmaker we do all those
videos Ben use this one it's easy to put
the equipment in it's a tough durable
backpack you know hostile environments
you know climate whatever you're not
gonna get [ __ ] up it's that could do
to a nylon could who do the nylon it's
tough as [ __ ] is what the government
uses you know it's what it's what our
government uses when they go in all
those third-world countries to help them
so you know they land in all these
places and all the locals like thank God
they're bringing nylon they're bringing
military-grade nylon here thank God
so that's what it is folks that's the
situation you know buy the [ __ ]
backpack get that kunai Pro gear Pro to
the gear you got to get that kunai you
know you're not gonna you're gonna find
these backpacks online this is where the
good stuff is you're not gonna find this
[ __ ] in Macy's some good sheets of
leather Gucci bag you know who are you
gonna beat with that and now can I bags
a good bag it's a good bag to beat
someone with maybe a riot cop who just
stumbled into a throng of protesters and
you have the upper hand you just have
beaten them with the kunai sure you
catch a taste but you know what you
doing it because you believe in
something it's good to believe in things
but if you believe in things you need to
have the kunai I mean that's what it is
folks that's what it is so go to kunai
ProGear com
tim is the code you get 15% off you're
gonna need to worry about a lot of
things when you're out there in the
field one thing you should not worry
about is your backpack you know worried
about getting getting beaten with sticks
worried about teargas worried about riot
police on horses crowd control getting
your ribs stomped out by a [ __ ]
stallion some fat cop from Staten Island
just beating on your [ __ ] ribcage
like he's [ __ ] like he's [ __ ]
Derek Jeter just swing listen you got to
worry about all that the last thing you
need to worry about when you're doing
civil disobedience is your [ __ ]
backpack that's all you just wanna you
want it you want to say hey no matter
what happens out here I got a backpack
that's gonna survive it you know can i
pro-gay
dot-com TI m CA and na e probe u dot-com
Tim I was I'm wondering if I should get
on tick-tock and I was I think tick-tock
is interesting because the younger
generation seems to not they did not
take social media seriously and tick
tock seems to be this you know it's kind
of you know a thing where you know
people do these really dumb videos where
it's like people are dancing or people
are falling down or people are kind of
but it all seems to be very fun and
casual and people are just kind of you
you're just kind of being a voyeur to an
extent and you're just watching people
do these you know funny wacky things
that way and and on its face it's a bit
ridiculous but it also what I think
about it it makes a lot more sense than
how generations above them have kind of
used social media like you know if you
said what is social media supposed to be
for is it supposed to be for 300
comments for fight about climate change
on Facebook you know is it or is it
supposed to be for just zany wacky goofy
[ __ ] that you could waste your time
watching while you're online at your
pote line that's what tick tock is so
that as you know and we saw will people
monetize it how are people I'm sure
eventually all that'll happen but like
as goofy and zany and stupid as it is
that's like yeah but that's kind of what
it should be you know like it should be
that it should be this thing where
people are like who cares yeah I've all
these followers but who cares and some
people I guess are taking it seriously
but it just it doesn't seem like a
serious thing you know and I think that
that but maybe I should get on it I mean
I don't know it's hard to know I mean I
mean I should go to Lisa's lounge you
just have them do tic TOCs
I don't even know I think they're all
dead it's so funny to go back to a bar
you hung out in and they're all dead
it's interesting it's like yeah they all
those people check out in their sixties
yeah
they check out in their sixties because
they live hard and they just check out
and they just you know that's what it is
that's Long Island baby
they love the Irishman they'd love the
Irishman man there'd be a screening of
the IRA I mean we'd be too long and
nobody would pay
but that's you know that's who that's
for you know those you know that's who
that's for those people that they view
the future with dread but they love the
past it's the same thing with Irish
people Irish people really hate the
future they're scared of it they dread
it but the past is always warm and
comforting and it's in their mind and
they love the idea of you know remember
how things used to be remember how
things were and they just you know and
that that is you know the people that I
really see connect unless I'm sure the
Irishmen there's an argument whose good
movie or whatever I have no interest in
hearing your argument that it's a good
[ __ ] movie but at the end of the day
it's like I think that's those type of
movies to me I just get to a point now
where I'm like I see so much of evidence
that there's no new ideas and there's so
many talented people that I know
personally who are struggling and could
bring a lot of new fun [ __ ] to the fore
and and none of them are getting
opportunities but they're remaking mad
about you and Frazier they're just remit
we did it we're done guys we don't need
to like nobody needs the constant
glorification of the past it was fun I
loved Frazier it was a great [ __ ]
show but let's move on let's do
something else
and it's just it's kind of depressing
everything's a romantic everything's a
remake it's like let's do something else
you know and when they do something new
it's always like euphoria and I don't
know if that's good or not but I I mean
I don't know what that it's just about
you know kids doing heroin in high
school is that what it's about yeah
doing webcam stuff so on their bodies
online yeah to older guys it's right hey
you know what this is what it is this is
where we're at least you're making a
show about how it is I don't know I mean
I just I was watching an Irishman and I
could just tell it immediately I was
like oh I know the people are gonna love
this I know that people are gonna
[ __ ] eat this up I'm gonna go back
and do Christmas with my family cuz I
realized it's more tragic until you've
built your new family or whatever it's
actually more tragic to go out you know
for the holidays with that you just just
you know it's it's really [ __ ] sad
out there and then you see some people's
tweets they're like I Love New York City
in the holidays cuz everybody's gone I
have the city to myself it's like oh god
poor guys putting a gun in his mouth
it's so nice I get the whole city to
myself everybody's gone with their
families and I'm just here enjoying an
empty Obon pond isn't this nice isn't it
fun no it's not you know it really is it
really is a [ __ ] tragedy you know but
how long have we done our three our
three a few other things I want to
discuss we're not on the porch right now
we're good we're looking for studio 2020
it's very cold in LA and you can't
really broadcast outside right now
really until the spring because it's
freezing and the winds are high the mics
don't sound good wait we really were
flirting today what if we move the whole
operation of Florida why not
what if we move the whole operation to
sunny Florida and I'm not talking about
immediately but eventually down the road
you know the prices in New York in LA of
their little bit ridiculous and when you
look at you know the bang for your buck
your Florida's got negatives sure you
know the bath salts - eating of the
faces we get it but I'm pretty sure that
you could find places where that's not
happening and I just I don't know that
when I was in Florida I find weird
feeling I was like I'm not gonna end up
in Florida you know my mother loved
Florida she was a [ __ ] mermaid
a Weeki Wachee mermaid I mean that's
where I come from I come from a woman
who swam around in a tank in Florida to
entertain truckers because strip clubs
weren't open you know they'd watch young
women float around in a tank with fins
on and then probably jerk off in there
cause that's where I come from and I
just wonder if that's where I'm going
there's something nice about Florida 79
degrees and he's freezing in LA right
there's something nice about it I'm
looking at it's inexpensive that I think
there's no income tax or it's very low
double-fist all your [ __ ] money down
there it just seems like maybe that's
where I where I end up eventually
I don't know weigh in people tell me if
I'm crazy or it's Florida the move build
a studio in the house travel do live
dates all around the country and just
live in Florida maybe have a little
apartment in New York bounce around you
know I'm not leaving LA anytime soon but
I'm just flirting with this idea Florida
I don't know it's where a lot of people
go to give up and that sounds nice I
won't be down there to give up I'll
still be funny but you know he could be
funny from anywhere do the show from
anywhere get on the go on the road and
entertain people from anywhere do I need
to be in LA you know yeah is it Canyon
living doesn't appeal to me I don't want
to live in a Canyon
you know there's some beautiful homes in
LA but there are millions and millions
and millions of dollars a traffic is
horrendous
I love the Comedy Store I love a lot of
my friends or love a lot of the comics
here that also you know that also
doesn't justify you spending 7 times the
amount of money on a home that you have
to evacuate like three to four times a
year because there's a fire just
surrounding your house you know yes it's
burning it's literally on fire so I
wonder I wonder if down the road that's
going to be a reality and I mean
somewhere in the space of around 24
months in two years I'm thinking if we
build a show up enough like you know do
we stay do I stay forever in LA I mean
if the weather in LA was great all year
round that would be one thing it's just
really not and the people that have
spent time here kind of know that's it's
kind of cold every now and then it will
rain I don't know I just I know Florida
is a swamp climate it's a little more
tropical but I don't know as I as I age
I'm like 34 and I'm like where do I want
to be 45 you know do I want to be 45 in
LA maybe if I really kid it out of the
park and we start making crazy money
but but even then it's like I don't know
there's something nice about Florida
what's the big con of Florida just the
hurricane season that's it the people
the people the people are the negative
the others the people you know the
pedophile parks and all that that's Shh
no that's that's pretty isolated I think
that the real I mean the weather there
you running issues to get hot and swampy
but you just look but you know you look
at the amount of money you pay I don't
know I just think this could it could be
the move
I got gonna get a bunch of messages from
people that are like they love Florida
you know there's just something nice
about going out to dinner at 3:30 p.m.
something nice something nice about it
going there into the backwoods you'd
have to go somewhere we could build a
nice big house or buy a house or an
apartment it would be inexpensive I have
no interest in spending a lot of money
down there so I want to go somewhere I'd
be put somewhat isolated if I isolate
myself I have to isolate myself and I'd
have to you know you know I wouldn't
want to be too isolated ever but I I
would I could I could probably go 20
minutes 30 minutes out of a city and
find something that's inexpensive and
just much better to live no traffic
light traffic you know get a studio
there or build one in the house and you
could go down there and golf mm-hmm you
send your kids to parkland I'm sure it's
safe now but like you know that's the
thought that's what I'm kicking around
in my head one day like today but it's
really cold I kicked that thought around
in my head I got maybe maybe down the
road a few years from now I I think
about a little relocation so I'm never
gonna do the winters in the Northeast
again I'm just not doing it
I'm not doing the New York City Way it's
just I'm not doing it
I just won't ever do it again and the
winters in LA are not great I'm not
loving them so I don't know maybe a nice
sunny Floridian maybe that's how I end
up like leg Rush Limbaugh just eatin
oxys talking into a microphone living in
Florida is it the worst life just
scratching my skin off eatin conch
fritters I don't know maybe not maybe
I'm crazy but there's something nice
about that state there's something scary
about it there's a lot of things that
are also very scary about it but there's
there's something when I was down there
I was in st. Pete Beach and I went you
know I don't know if the future of this
I don't know if the future of the way
that I exist in this business is New
York or LA I don't need to be here I
don't need it I do need it right now but
I might not need it in the future and I
certainly don't need to be in New York I
don't need to do 13 comedy shows a night
till I drop dead I just don't need to do
it god bless everyone that's doing that
but you're missing out on other things
you could be a great comedian and not
get up 75 times a night you just can do
it you don't need to just [ __ ]
there's other things you should
experience in the world besides getting
on stage in a dark room and telling
everybody you know they need to [ __ ]
listen here and you need to laugh I love
it it's great but I'm like hey could I
[ __ ] I could go on the road I could
you know it's it's you know eventually
that might be that maybe they and I mean
let's say there's other places in
Georgia there's a lot of other places I
have friends that are very happy outside
of Atlanta there's something about
Florida something Florida that I like I
gotta take you down there I want you to
really see see what it's about when's
your next date down there I don't know I
don't have one
there's a comedy club in Key West
funny guy from Boston and Tom Dustin
runs I could talk to him about getting
some but think the keys are not really
indicative of flarb and the keys are
like it so that's a whole other thing
but it would give you the idea of
Florida but I mean I could go down there
and get a date I was just assigned
splitters which I loved you know but who
knows I mean this is just you know it's
just again we're just playing around
here we don't know what's gonna happen
we might be in LA well I might stay in
LA forever you know I don't know but it
also might just be like well when do you
pull the switch at what point do you
pull the escape I'm just sick you know I
read these like the the people there's
people that I started comedy with God
loved them that are still doing open
mics in Brooklyn they're still filing
into a room and putting your name on a
piece of paper and somebody's pulling
out of a bucket and it's like guys I
know I don't hate on anyone god bless
you and you know I hope that you find
the success you want or whatever number
one I'm like succeeding it's still not
great so there's that I will tell you
that it's it's better than being in
Brooklyn pulling a get my name pulled
out of a bucket but it's you know it's
still you know so the idea of like just
your entire life your entire life I
think just doing just your entire life
you go yeah I just did stand-up and
nothing else I didn't do anything else I
never I just you know which is a crew is
great but it's also like are you missing
out on literally everything else you
know and then some of that hit me when I
was sitting in that [ __ ] restaurant
and Thanksgiving last night I'm like
what am I missing out I'm missing out on
a lot to do this I mean I'm missing out
on a lot to be on the road constantly to
be just broadcasting all the time to be
do is there a way to do this it's less
time intensive where I have more time to
create a life that's more meaningful
then just this business because you see
the people where their entire life is
this business they're rotted they rot
from the inside and you just see them
and there's nothing behind their eyes
they just become vessels and then
everything's about you know just trying
to make
they're still just trying to and I get
it you want to keep building and you
want more and the audiences have to be
bigger and I get all of that I'm it's
very much in me to keep being that
person it's how I'm wired
but you think to yourself at a certain
point do you just want to get out of
that and and still be a comedian and
still perform and still do the show but
not be running around LA or running
around New York proving what what are
you proving at a certain point at a
certain point it really is that's the
[ __ ] question that's the question
what am i proving I know I'm funny the
people that enjoy what I do know I'm
funny
Who am I proving some [ __ ] executive
who doesn't know anything you know some
executive who's basically kept their job
by not having any discerning to and just
sitting around and being a yes-man and
just sitting there and you know saying
crazy you know stuff and just sitting
there and being like oh yes well we just
want you know strong point of view or
look we're just funny first we want
funny for it oh shut up we're all being
funny you don't care so what are we
doing here there's no movie coming maybe
I'm wrong about that but you know I'm
settling into the idea that if this just
gets if we just get more people to enjoy
what we're doing right now then what the
[ __ ] is the point of living 20 minutes
from the Paramount studio why what are
we doing I'm not 20 I'm adding these
rooms with these people I'm like you you
you're gonna be fired in a few months
oh you know I get it it's like at a
certain point you go what am i doing the
dance for what do I you know you you
know a certain certain you guys at a
certain point the guy I love the comedy
store I love the stand they both work me
they're greats my New York home clubs my
LA home club
I go on the road my agents grade she
puts me in all these places but it's
like there's some clubs that just don't
[ __ ] with me in New York and that's fine
too I don't care anymore I'm not mad
about it anymore like I used to you know
you submitted veils when you're a
comedian you email a club and go book me
some of them just don't book you and for
a while you're real mad at that and
you're like I gotta [ __ ] get I gotta
convince this [ __ ] person that I'm
fun and then you got I don't know I
don't know I don't know I know that's
fine good for them you might not feel
you're not feeling me that's okay I'm
not gonna spend my entire life clawing
and you know it's unhealthy to spend
your entire life never chasing a dream
but it's also on very unhealthy to just
keep chasing forever chase chase just
keep you know listen we all want to be
better at what we're doing we all want
to get funnier and sharper we want to
build audiences but a lot of the tools
to do that now are in our possession
they're in our hands and for me to run
around and just convince gatekeepers and
I'm good or just convince Pete it just
seems to be a fool's errand and that's
you know there's a lot of people that
listen to the show that might be
comedian it's a fool's errand you can
just go to people right now and then
just figure out a way to get them the
content that they want get them [ __ ]
that makes them laugh and that's where
the idea of like it doesn't mean
quitting it doesn't mean you know it
just means like am I gonna truck kill
myself trying to be Kevin Hart is that
the point is the point to spend the rest
of my life trying to play arenas I don't
know maybe it is but maybe it's not
maybe the point is to go hey in a year
or two when I when we built the show up
more and we built the money up more
there's another way to do this so that I
don't end up you know at a lodge in the
middle of Calabasas eating a
Thanksgiving dinner
that sucks with my friend who's you know
I don't know what he's in the CBD
business I don't know what he does sells
incense or whatever and you know maybe
that maybe that's not maybe it's not
worth it
it's not worth it folks you know maybe
it isn't maybe you know you get to a
point you start really reading stuff and
you go well what's the point what's the
point again so you make money and you
hustle and you get on the dumb little
like we're all at the end of this
everybody's gonna die and no one's gonna
remember you you know what I really
realized that I was sitting in Spokane
comedy club and they're real fun I went
on stage as a joke I said the audience
is real white here and they all clapped
at one damn right and I'm like well this
is fun huh I was sitting in Spokane
comedy club best green remember they
have Mario and they have great hot dogs
and you can play you know the old school
like Super Mario World and I love the
plant please book me again I love your
green room it's a great club I was
kidding
the crowds are fine so one listen some
of them just want to take another look
at the Holocaust
sure that's fine again here's my mouth
get me into trouble
I didn't mean it it's all fine love it
honored to be there love to go back
anyway
point is this but again what you know at
a certain point it's like I gotta say
what I want to say here so you know if
nobody can't a got banned from a Long
Island Club cuz I said that the audience
came into sweatpants they did then came
into starter jackets and sweatpants I'm
sorry they did I'm also a slob that's
why I did well there but you see now I
can't work there anymore so it's like
okay I guess I could just never open my
mouth I shouldn't say anything you know
I can't make an honest observation god
forbid I do that it's not my [ __ ] job
is it comedian to make an honest
observation and go yeah a lot of people
in the audience at the Long Island Club
happen to be wearing sweatpants on
Saturday night and that's just what it
is it's a great club I love the owners I
like a lot of the other comics that work
there it's just I commented on the
audience it's just the truth okay
right this book can't comedy club and
the hot dogs they have are named after
comedians they have the Joan Rivers to
have the Richard Pryor they have the
Carlin and I think I even posted on
Instagram oh she was Munoz for as you
get in this business you're gonna end up
a hot dog
you end up a hotdog you end up a hotdog
there's some white supremacist orders
and goes can I get the Richard Pryor
which is ironic but like that's that's
where it ends here folks what you're
running a race for no one you're running
a race for nobody you're gonna be a
hotdog
best case those are legends you're not
even gonna be a hotdog hotdog is best
case you're a [ __ ] picture on a wall
you're a portrait you're a [ __ ] clip
that somebody plays you go to history
book no one reads you know I'm not
telling you to not go out and pursue the
thing you want to do because I wouldn't
I wouldn't have life be any other way I
wouldn't I wouldn't have wanted to stay
a mortgage guy whatever I I'm still so
[ __ ] I love making those videos and I
love broadcasting and I love doing
stand-up comedy but at a certain point
you have to look around and you go how
do we build a life here that is somewhat
sustainable and is it in a place that's
constantly on fire
where I'm tap-dancing for soulless
executives who have no [ __ ] clue
whose networks are melting in front of
them and I got to sit there in a room
and look at these people who'd these
people should be strapped to a gurney
they should have straight jackets on and
I have to sit there and and try to like
it like um how about so maybe this is
the show eighties no show this is the
show there's nothing else it's me and
the [ __ ] people you don't like it
don't come don't listen if we is the
only thing that's gonna happen is if we
put 20 cameras on me and give me a
budget it's just gonna be some [ __ ]
26 year old it's like I don't know I
think some of the things you said we
need to just kind you know it just is
what it it's not it's you know nobody
gives a [ __ ] they don't let me make an
Ozark he's not gonna be Game of Thrones
with Tim Dylan it's just not unless next
week it is in which will delete this
episode
know how it works don't come at me what
about your integrity eighty people are
like Oh your integrity is clearly for
sale it's like if it's capitalism dummy
I'm not sacrificing kids but if you want
to give me a dumb game show I'll
probably do it but you're not even
giving me the dumb game show so why am I
here what am I here to do just talking
to a mic to spend crazy amount of money
to live in the house of a crazy woman
who I love but I live in her crazy house
cuz it's a block from the Hollywood
improv a club that does it work to me
once a month they go hey can you come in
at 3 a.m. and do a spot in our lab which
should have been a vape shop no no I
can't I'll sit home thank you thanks
again what is the daddy's going to
Florida is what's what's gonna happen
I'm starting to feel like a sucker
starting to feel like a sucker every
time I [ __ ] get parking validated to
go sit in a high-rise with some goon and
tell him why he should give me the next
version of Deal or No Deal
how about this how about no deal how
about a show called No Deal where you
film me moving to Florida the next time
I see an executive I can sit down and go
when's the last time you saw your kids
they're probably doing coke right now
it's stealing people's jewelry in some
mansion why don't you spend a little
time with them a little more time with
them and a little less time with me
figuring out what the next version of
Deal or No Deal is gonna be what
mainstream entertainment it doesn't even
excite me I'm gonna go sit sit there
with Jimmy Fallon and he'll talk about
what it's just not for me
I don't care what am I gonna [ __ ]
digging it digging it what am I gonna go
down a float and the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade dressed like just lame max
well it's not
she's not gonna happen I mean so it's
anybody's [ __ ] guess why I'm [ __ ]
I love the Comedy Store and I love my
friends that are here and I love the
podcasts that are here and I'm inspired
by the other talented people here which
is why I'm here for the moment and why
I'll stay here but I'm getting older and
and this business is for people that are
very young and they can tolerate large
doses of [ __ ] forever and I don't
know how long I can tolerate all of that
horseshit for and it's not just this
business it's any business it's anybody
out there that stitch that you know
trying the [ __ ] claw their way to the
next level of something is eventually
you have to decide what the [ __ ] is the
point what is the point you know what is
the money worth what is the money worth
the only thing I value is freedom I'm
free to do what I want you know if I if
I was making a shitload of money but I
had to get up early everyday and go do
some [ __ ] I hate it you know would
that be worth it probably not it depends
on how much money it is but you look
back and you go what the [ __ ] was the
point
you know what was the point of all this
you know you know and and that that's
that's what got me now that's what I've
been thinking about in the last 24 hours
I've been thinking about like starting a
militia you know and I'm not hating on
the Hollywood improv don't use me it's
okay you know it is what it is but it's
just funny I live around the block and
all this [ __ ] money it's like I'm
also close to the store which is great
but like it's the idea of like you know
sometimes I'll get the avails email
they're semi avails in they don't book
me and I get mad and I'm like but I
don't even need so what am i doing so I
can go to a spot at midnight for freedom
for $15 for some confused tourists to
came to LA enough enough already
rein it in pack it up leave it for
someone else
oh here's Michael and Michael goes
Michael goes to be fair if we had even a
great but not out-of-this-world meal
yesterday we would have forgotten about
it last night by tomorrow okay well I
thought he was complaining again I'm
just at the point now the tolerance I
have for people's horseshit is
decreasing and it you need to have a
tolerance for it to live here you really
do I just like you know eventually I'm
just saying I'm just saying it might
there might be a change of venue not
tomorrow not soon maybe sooner then I
would imagine I don't know definitely
not you know yeah I'm here for another
solid year probably more than that is we
still got to build the [ __ ] show but
it's it's it's at a point we start to
look around and you start to see some of
the other people that you're around and
you people are just I get it man you
just lit you're just on that hamster
wheel of like just you know the there's
a certain age where desperation you know
when you're younger you can be you
should be a little hungry and desperate
you should be in that situation where
you're like you know you know you're
you're running on all cylinders you're
trying to me and then at a certain age
you go what's the what's the rest of my
life gonna look like am I gonna be a
person that you know at a certain age is
still just or we have the tools in other
comics back back in the day you didn't
have the tools you know back in the
irishman you didn't you you had the
[ __ ] live here you had to live in New
York I just think now there's a lot of
people that that are successfully doing
in other places and I think maybe that's
that might be the solution I don't know
I don't know Tim Dylan comedy calm for
live tickets Bridgeport Connecticut
when does this come out Saturday so it
comes out the first yeah so December 5th
through the 7th if you're in Connecticut
or know anyone who is I'm at the stress
factory Providence what
in the comedy connection December 13
through the 14th timonium Maryland
McGoo B's January 9th through the 11th
Las Vegas Nevada this thing called the
laughed out queer Comedy Festival its
non-traditional gay comedian so god only
knows it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
interesting Tyra Vera's running it who's
a hilarious comedian he's in Vegas and
he's what's great about ties he
certainly he doesn't mind a little
controversy that's what I like about him
he doesn't mind the little guy he's what
a real when people ask what a real like
comic is it's really ty Rivera that's a
guy who is more of a comic than all
these [ __ ] drones that like you know
file into these offices every day to
write
you know garbage jokes or whatever he
really puts himself out there doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's deeply human if he's
wrong a bit a cat was wrong but he'll
let it fly so go follow that guy and he
just lets it fly and III predict can you
pull up when he when he talks about
Monique bring up ty Rivera talking about
Monique this is the one of the funniest
things I've ever seen go to his YouTube
channel Monique is suing Netflix because
she does it she thinks she should have
gotten more money ty Rivera has to one
of the funniest things I've ever seen go
I don't know if it's a suit I think go
to his YouTube he has a podcast called
unbothered or something and he talks
about Monique but it's just one of the
funniest things it's just a great he
just kind of sums up like the whole
thing and it's just kind of funny it's
just kind of funny let's see he goes
right there just thank God for flame
Monroe who's the who's the who's the
great comic that went on The Breakfast
Club that's another great interview you
should watch his flame Monroe on The
Breakfast Club try to find Tyra hair
Monique
please can we play this on the show
please everybody Tyra barrier for the
absolute best LG
btq comedian in the world so Monique had
decided that she was going to sue
Netflix she went ahead and filed the
paperwork she put out a statement on her
Instagram I believe where she was like
hey my and I'm gonna tell you guys I
went to see Monique show here in Las
Vegas that it was at the SLS at the time
which is now back to being the Sahara
again and what I can tell you about
Monique's show is that it was good it
was fun it was a decent show to watch
but was i holding my sides was i like
yeah this needs to be a special and she
needs to get millions of dollars for it
honestly no I wasn't and I'm not a hater
on any level
I do like Monique a lot I've liked her
stuff in the past I know different
people were upset about different things
that she said and her situation with the
movie that she did precious where she
didn't feel like they were treating her
right but it just seems to be turning
into a pattern where Monique always
thinks she's being shorted in some way
and I don't think that a lot of the
general public feels like her talent
necessarily matches the level that she
thinks that she's supposed to be at
she's just not one of the voices of our
time and she's not particularly
charismatic in the way that nobody's
sitting a letter about Monique and a
good or bad way nobody's like oh I can't
wait till the new Monique special drops
or so it's just so fun he just lets it
fly
he doesn't Kyle of it he goes he's just
not one of the voices of our time you're
just not one of the voices evident by
the way that was summed up better than
most people could sum up anything he
goes you're just not one of the voices
of our time what a [ __ ] way to say it
you just what it like it's just funny
so he's booked this festival in Las
Vegas and it'll be I think it's me it's
Mila innopolis it's the gay guy Greg
Johnson who's the white nationalist
account occurrence I'm kidding these are
all junk
I'm a comedian and these are jokes but I
don't know but there's very funny comics
on there but it's just funny which gives
us like tie it's ty Rivera's fest of all
and Johnson sharp who's another funny
comic in Vegas but it's just a funny
idea I watched that money clip man I
don't know where I was I was just
laughing so hard he was just like hey
just not wanna she's not a voice of our
time which is such a [ __ ] funny
no no shade the Monique who I'd never
met and I don't give a [ __ ] but I think
Moe needs hilarious we've watched some
among yet and you know are queens of
comedy she's just very funny she's very
fun I mean it's just literally [ __ ]
hilarious but who knows what's going on
I didn't see your new show I didn't see
a new special I just think it's so funny
and tuyas no problem just putting it out
there
he'll just put it out there like he did
a review of the people that did the
Netflix chats the 15 minutes ends and it
was so funny he's like yeah he said nice
things about me but he was just like
ayzik did they tell them not to kill not
to kill I don't know but you need this
do you need guys like this you just
don't give a [ __ ] he's living in Vegas
he's not in LA he's not doing the tap
dance
he's just you're gonna get the way he
feels whether it is what you like or
what you don't like you're just gonna
get his unvarnished uncensored opinion
and it's just very very funny I mean
it's just he just doesn't care
I mean it's just put what I'll what else
let me see what else is he reviewed
anything else originally but I just love
the egos uh but yeah but he does like um
he does like a UH Gina Rodriguez use the
n-word it's just funny man anyway it's
just funny it's just so that's it let's
go back to the dates when is that cuz
that's in Vegas I'll be there I think it
is January 18th January 18th I'll be
there it'll be funny
Chicago's a nice comedy club Wednesday
the 5th through the 8th
Theriault Canada the grand raw theater
people keep asking me when are you gonna
be in Toronto Friday February 14th and
February and February 15th there is a
live podcast as well in addition to me
doing stand-up there so grab tickets for
that it's gonna be a lot of fun I don't
know I'm pretty sure that's a bill that
I'm on with mark norm and Shane Gillis I
mean it's [ __ ] crazy check that out
before but I'm pretty sure that those
guys are involved in that as well
um Indio California fantasy Springs
Resort Hotel and Casino February 27th
and 28th caroline's this is the big one
New York City
March 12th through the 14th Thursday
Friday Saturday at Caroline's amazing
show we are you know really gonna put on
a great show I'm gonna have great
openers I'm gonna have people that are
really really funny I might have a few
guest spots you might see ah maybe I'll
admit I'm not gonna even tell you who
these people are gonna be but I'm just
gonna try to entice them to come out and
do guest spots on the show and if you
know who some of my friends are and some
of the people that I podcast with you
might have an idea of who these people
are gonna be I'm not telling you because
I don't know if I'll get him but
Bloomington Minnesota April 9th to the
11th I'm at the house of comedy Phoenix
Arizona House a comedy May 7 through the
9th Edmonton Canada the comic strip
June 18th through the 20th there's more
dates it'll be added those are the dates
that we have now if you go to Tim Dylan
comedy calm we have links on the website
for all of those tickets but which is
funny man
it's just funny and like like I said
it's kind of the you know it's like with
you know I would tie it's kind of like
you get to a point we just don't give a
[ __ ] you stop giving you can't give a
[ __ ] your whole career you you start to
get unfunny and I understand if people
cutting you big checks to be whatever do
that I'm not hating I'm do that I'm not
but nobody's like I think that I'm not
meant to get those big checks to be
palatable to the masses I gotta be you
gotta like what I'm doing and that's
that if you don't like what I'm doing it
is what it is but
those are the dates that's the way it is
folks the go watch the Irishmen tell me
that it's not a hunk of [ __ ] we know
it's bad a CGI corpse is walking around
just not what it you know you know I
don't know I just it's an interesting
time it's an interesting time and I'm
wondering where it all goes where it all
leads were very excited subscribe to us
on YouTube the Tim Dillon show on
YouTube that is where all the stuff goes
it's where the podcasts go everyone who
asked me about why did the podcast come
down let's address this because a lot of
people you know I have a lot of sober
rational fans and think it's you know
because the CIA is activated my cell so
what happened was Sam Tripoli's YouTube
channel came down Sam's a friend of ours
he does tinfoil hat we've been on his
live show we're gonna do more live stuff
with him in the future I'll always have
a lot of fun with Sam Sam's Channel came
down because there was some ad and I
don't know if the ad was for CBD or
whatever it was but YouTube deleted his
whole channel now his channel came back
up and they you know so we have ads on
our podcast for CBD for blue 2 for all
these things we don't know we don't know
what could be gambling could be gambling
could be my bookie we don't know so we
took all of the podcasts off the channel
because we wanted to figure out what's
going on and then we'll probably and
we're gonna edit them we'll edit out
what needs to be edited out we'll reload
them so that you can show people too but
we want them out there we want you
watching them we want you showing your
friends then we want all of that but the
reality is it's it's crucial that we
don't have the channel ripped down you
know we went on rogue and we doubled our
subscribers we're around 40,000
subscribers for the channel now
hopefully that builds it continues to
build what we don't want to do is get
the [ __ ] channel yanked down and if
the channels yanked down then it's you
know then yeah it's all for nothing so
what we're doing is we're trying to
figure out what the best move is going
forward and how to you know handle this
to not get our channel yanked down
but like you know that's that's where
we're at and going forward we're gonna
have to just be careful we're gonna have
to be careful a little bit with the ads
do we upload it's just the way it is
it's not we don't really have a choice
you know
now if the patreon is big enough we tell
these companies to [ __ ] off we're just a
Florida we're just in sunny Florida
sitting there with lizards not giving a
[ __ ] then that might be the move I don't
know the move um I'm back on keto I had
no bread today no sugar today I've
smoked nine Marber lights so I hadn't
smoked in a long time but that's where
we're at where are we at now timelines
our 41
yeah good nice and long mm-hmm so I mean
that's it folks go become a regular at a
dirtbag bar go through a life wait don't
don't do that don't do that don't do
that folks I don't know what to tell you
or do it I don't know some people need
some people need that they need to go
there and they need to they need to you
know they need to peer into the void I
need it too so that's it get tickets to
live dates patreon episodes are coming
up we try to get ray on the patreon as
much as we can we love ray you guys know
the diehards of the show know that ray
and me started the show we're living in
different places maybe we get ray come
to come down to Florida what we'll put
them on the patreon all the time you
know if you're at listen if you love the
show that me and Ray did for you I love
doing the show solo now it's just that's
the way the show is a lot of people like
the solo show but you know we also love
Ray so ray comes on a lot of our patreon
episodes we have fun and we do exactly
what we used to do so if you guys are
into that you know it's $5 a month you
get those episodes and he's uh he's a
wild man and it's a lot of fun so as
always thank you for listening
enjoy it's the holiday season merch is
coming the shirt the life of the big
city shirt is coming out
very soon and we've had a a professional
designer worked very very hard on this
and you'll get that joke when the cher
comes up but it's it's a you know very
very beautiful design intricate
beautiful design that were very proud of
because we're going to go into the
garment business we're going to go into
the fashion which is what comedians I
think will do I think a lot of comedians
that are big into the merge game they'll
eventually get in you know I have no
interest in that really no interest in
you know selling sneakers but a lot of
other people will be very good at it you
know some people are phenomenal at
Mullin I was on the phone dick mom the
other day he he's like easy [ __ ] guys
amazing he knows the ins and outs of
shipping it out even the guys [ __ ] a
met like you know he's so smart and he
does it all himself and his shirts are
great and they're very funny and check
that [ __ ] out what does it come techcom
dad what is that aside over there let me
see him because his shirts are [ __ ]
great and he does it all himself and he
fussed so he was giving me kind of
advice on how to do it yeah come town
yeah come downtown go get his shirts cuz
they're [ __ ] great you know this is
another part of the business off to
learn but he was he's very uh you know
he took me through it and I appreciate
that um so you know by the life in the
big city shirt when it comes out we're
taking a dollar from every sale and
we're going to donate it to David Koch
so that might entice you as well
we're gonna give a dollar from every
sale to the Koch family the Koch
brothers who's alive I think one of them
just died yeah one died let's see who
did well we're giving it to the other
one
I like I like knowing that they got
billions son I like knowing that they're
trying to strangle us with their money
Oh David died David died who's the other
one let's see there's the other coke
berry no I forget his name Tommy Tommy
coke Frederick Frederick we're gonna
give all the money to Freddie so every
dollar from the shark goes to Fred Koch
and Koch Industries so because it's the
holidays
so we wanted to find an organization and
we decided the Salvation Army's little
shady Red Cross's little shady and we
might as well just give it to the cokes
that's where it's going anyway
so dollar from every sale goes
personally to Fred Koch we're gonna
write checks to Fred Koch should we send
him I'm not even kidding she would just
send a cheque to Fred Koch for money
holla larious would that be we just
write a cheque to Fred Koch send it to
him to the Park Avenue apartment in
Manhattan he lives in he has like a 40
million dollar apartment on Park Avenue
just send him a check
Hague Fred this is from the Tim Dylan
show in LA now but soon to be located in
sunny South Beach Florida this is for
you Fred use the money well we know you
will
we know you I trust Fred Koch with the
money folks a lot more than I trust a
Red Cross those those are all fraud says
the Salvation Army in the Red Cross I
don't know I don't know if they really
help people so that's where we're gonna
send the money directly to Fred Freddie
we love you Freddie Fred Koch we're
gonna write all the checks to Charlie
Kirk we'll give him all the money give
them all the money directly goodbye